[Música]
todo listo en Reino Unido para la
coronación del Rey Carlos III este
sábado llega el momento esperado por
miles de nacionales y extranjeros
fanáticos de la realeza representantes
de más de 100 gobiernos ya se encuentran
en territorio británico
el 11 de mayo Estados Unidos deja de
aplicar el título 42 la ley que permitía
la expulsión inmediata de migrantes
alegando motivos de salud pública esto
en medio de la confusión entre las
personas migrantes en tránsito hacia el
país y advertencias de Washington de que
no abrirá la frontera
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
declaró el fin de la emergencia
internacional por la pandemia de Kobe 19
la enfermedad dejó casi 7 millones de
víctimas mortales registradas el
director del organismo pidió no bajar la
guardia Pues el fin de la emergencia no
supone el fin de la pandemia
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 mi nombre Rodrigo sedano y es
un placer estar con ustedes abrimos este
Informativo en Reino Unido en donde este
sábado tiene lugar la coronación del Rey
Carlos III ante una gran expectativa
todo está listo y miles de fanáticos de
la corona británica han esperado la
llegada de este día con emoción Para
ello se trata de uno de los
acontecimientos más importantes del año
emoción es lo que sienten muchos
británicos a la espera de la coronación
del Rey Carlos III en el caso de
margaret Tyler la fascinación por la
familia real comenzó de niña cuando
recortaba fotos de Carlos III y su
hermana Ana una afición que la llevó a
llenar su casa de este tipo de
decoraciones hay quien fuma hay quien
bebe quien se va de vacaciones yo no
hago nada de eso estoy acá viendo la
realeza y que ha hecho que espere este
momento con muchas expectativas ya que
recuerda el Rey Carlos desde que era un
niño tiene una mirada bonita no crees
que sí creo que está pensando oh Dios en
que me he metido
pero los británicos no son los únicos
que esperan este momento con emoción y
vamos para allá estoy tan emocionada
para una web estadounidense de 71 años y
fervientes seguidora de la realeza
británica Esta es una ocasión muy
especial tras varias bodas y varios
jubileos tiene la oportunidad de asistir
a una coronación por primera vez
nadie lo hace como los británicos la
pompa y la circunstancias no tenemos
nada parecido en Estados Unidos
como muchos otros fans de la corona
Weber voló desde Connecticut Estados
Unidos a Londres solo para estar
presente durante la ocasión la primera
vez que hizo algo parecido fue en 1986
para asistir a la boda del príncipe
Andrew con Sara Duquesa de York pero
ahora en su tienda de campaña frente al
buckingham Palace rodeada de banderas o
fotos y figuras de la corona espera por
algo mucho más grande Estoy feliz por
estar aquí y formar parte de la historia
no había pasado algo parecido en 70 años
como ellas a miles de Seguidores de la
realeza británica esperan vivir el
cuento de hadas frente al palacio cuando
los reyes crucen con su carroza
acompañados Por un desfile de 5000
miembros de las fuerzas armadas
les recordamos que en France 24
Tendremos una programación especial con
motivo de esta coronación del Rey Carlos
III los acompañaremos con toda la
información durante la jornada
y el próximo 11 de mayo expira el título
42 y la confusión sigue reinando entre
las personas migrantes en tránsito hacia
Estados Unidos Washington advierte que
no abrirá la frontera y plantea nuevos
mecanismos para evitar que los migrantes
lleguen a territorio estadounidense a
través de los pasos fronterizos con
México Marina sardinha con los detalles
incertidumbre de un lado al otro de la
frontera México estadounidense a menos
de una semana de la eliminación del
título 42 sé que lo quieren retirar el
11 pero no se sabe si es verdad o es
mentira en los comentarios Igual yo voy
para adelante yo voy a quedarme aquí
porque yo he pasado he sufrido mucho me
han robado he pasado de todo yo voy para
adelante la normativa fue implantada por
el expresidente Donald Trump para
devolver en caliente a los migrantes con
la excusa de la emergencia sanitaria
ahora Washington prevé la llegada masiva
de migrantes a partir del jueves y
advierte de consecuencias
la frontera no está abierta y no estará
con posterioridad al 11 de mayo
en un entorno posterior al título 42
utilizaremos nuestras autoridades de
expulsión acelerada en virtud del título
8 del código de Estados Unidos eso nos
permite expulsar a individuos muy
rápidamente
con la nueva Norma Estados Unidos
advirtió que los migrantes que no puedan
demostrar que son Víctimas de
persecución o torturan sus naciones de
origen serán expulsados y podrían
sancionarlos con hasta cinco años de
prohibición de ingreso al territorio
estadounidense las organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos denuncian que la
búsqueda de asilo es un derecho legal y
sigue siendo atacado por Estados Unidos
lo que está reemplazando el título 42 es
la prohibición de tránsito también
conocida como la prohibición de asilo
habrá dos centros de procesamiento uno
en Guatemala y otro en Colombia donde la
gente tendrá que ir si quiere pedir
asilo en Estados Unidos
Mientras tanto México reconoció un flujo
importante de personas en tránsito por
su territorio y llama a los migrantes a
informarse sobre las vías legales y a no
caer en engaños Han sido 1.191 días bajo
la emergencia sanitaria global por el
covid-19 pero este viernes la
Organización Mundial de la Salud puso
fin a esta declaratoria fue un periodo
en el que los sistemas sanitarios de
todo el mundo se pusieron a prueba
frente a que en muchos territorios
sobrepasó los recursos disponibles el
siguiente es un recuento del impacto que
dejó el virus y de la lucha para
detenerlo
la peor pandemia de las últimas décadas
dejó una huella difícil de borrar en
Perú este país cuenta con la tasa de
fallecimientos per cápita más altas de
todo el mundo
667,6 víctimas mortales por cada 100.000
habitantes la Organización Mundial de la
Salud contabiliza que unas siete
millones de personas han perdido la vida
pero estima que debido al subregistro la
cifras reales de al menos 20 millones de
muertos
el continente americano es en donde más
vida se han perdido en relación con su
población seguido por Europa en total
Estados Unidos China India y Francia han
sido las naciones con el mayor número de
casos detectados una cifra que va de la
mano de la capacidad de pruebas para
realizar el mundo desarrolló las vacunas
en tiempo récord y comenzó a aplicar las
primeras de ellas contra el virus en
diciembre de 2020 nueve meses después de
la declaratoria de la emergencia
sanitaria global por parte de la OMS
para finales de abril del presente año
en todo el mundo se habían aplicado
13.300 millones de dosis chile es el
único país de toda América que ha
conseguido aplicar el esquema de
vacunación completo a más del 90% de su
población África ha sido el continente
con la tasa más baja de todo el planeta
con la llegada de las vacunas y el mundo
comenzó a frenar el impacto de la
pandemia para enero de 2021 se llegaron
a registrar más de 100.000 muertos en
una semana mientras que a finales de
abril de este año el registro fue de
3.500 fallecidos en el mismo periodo el
covid-19 no se ha ido la OMS pide no
bajar la guardia pero cuando se
decretará el fin de la pandemia de
acuerdo con la OMS una pandemia
realmente termina cuando la siguiente
comienza
en algunas regiones de la Guatemala
rural donde la mayor parte de la
población es de origen Maya los índices
de malnutrición infantil alcanzan cifras
récord la pobreza y la falta de acceso a
educación son consecuencias de los
problemas nutricionales pero también son
sus causas nuestra corresponsal Aurora
byú nos trae los detalles
va a cumplir dos años si la delgadez de
sus brazos revela un preocupante esta
duda salud en el armario digamos que
están
en Guatemala es el país con la tasa de
desnutrición Crónica infantil más alta
de latinoamérica según acción contra el
hambre y aquí en el departamento de
Huehuetenango es donde se encuentra la
mayor cantidad de niños con hambre la
inseguridad alimentaria en esas tierras
áridas se agudizó por el cambio
climático dejando desemparadas a varias
familias
ya no hay nada que hacer con él
no sé qué va a ser de mi hijo
siempre ha estado enfermo
me da mucho tristeza por mi bebé para
comer cuando uno se salda con muerte es
la desnutrición acarrea otras secuelas
con el estómago vacío los estudiantes no
tienen el desarrollo cognitivo
suficiente para facilitar el aprendizaje
cuando yo hago lectura con ellos apenas
me leen palabras por la falta de
alimentación en sus hogares aquí cuando
empezamos el ciclo escolar pues muchos
niños se inscriben ya tarde por lo mismo
que los padres de familia lo llevan a
trabajar en las fincas para para tener
de Qué comer
para salir de esa espiral la fundación
football de Henry le apuesta a la
educación nutricional de las madres
que mejor verdad que de su huerto para
su cocina tener un huerto fecundo y
saber aprovecharlo puede marcar la
diferencia para los niños de la
comunidad vemos verdad familias que los
dos jefes del hogar no este son de
escolaridad muy baja Entonces eso es lo
que les limita a conseguir un buen
trabajo afecta a los niños porque no se
les da la alimentación que ellos
requieren según las Naciones Unidas al
ritmo actual Guatemala necesitaría 100
años para erradicar la desnutrición
Crónica infantil
hasta aquí llega este informativo sigan
en France 24
[Música]